[Music]
in 1984 an enterprising Australian
doctor named Barry Marshall decided to
take a risk too many of his patients
were complaining of severe abdominal
pain due to stomach ulcers which are
sores in the lining of the upper
intestinal tract at the time few
effective treatments for ulcers existed
and many sufferers required
hospitalization or even surgery
desperate for answers
dr. Marshall swallowed a cloudy broth of
bacteria collected from the stomach of
one of his patients soon
dr. Marshall was experiencing the same
abdominal pain bloating and vomiting ten
days later a camera called an endoscope
peered inside his insides Marshalls
stomach was teeming with the same
bacteria as his patient he'd also
developed gastritis or severe
inflammation of the stomach the hallmark
precursor of ulcers
dr. Marshalls idea challenged a
misconception that still persists to
this day that ulcers are caused by
stress food or too much stomach acid
Marshall thought the culprit was
bacterial infections initially his idea
was considered crazy by the brightest
medical minds on the planet but in 2005
he and dr. Robin Warren received the
ultimate validation when they were
awarded the Nobel Prize for medicine our
stomachs are j-shaped organs with
surprisingly intricate ecosystems awash
in hormones and chemicals the stomach is
under constant attack by digestive
enzymes bile proteins microbes and the
stomach's own acid in response it
produces bicarbonate mucus and
phospholipids called prostaglandins to
maintain the integrity of its own lining
this delicate balance is constantly
regulated and referred to as mucosal
defense since the mid-1800s doctors
thought stress alone caused most stomach
ulcers patients were given
antidepressants or tranquilizers and
told to visit health spas this belief
eventually shifted to the related notion
of spicy foods and stress as culprits
yet no convincing study has ever
demonstrated that emotional upset
psychological distress or spicy food
directly causes ulcer disease
by the mid 20th century it was widely
accepted that excess hydrochloric acid
prompted the stomach to eat itself
fervent proponents of this idea were
referred to as the acid mafia the
biggest hole in this theory was that
antacids only provide temporary relief
we now know that some rare ulcers are
indeed caused by too much hydrochloric
acid but they make up less than 1% of
all cases dr. Marshall and dr. Warren
pinpointed a spiral-shaped bacteria
called Helicobacter pylori or h pylori
as the real offender h pylori is one of
humanity's oldest and most frequent
companions having joined us at least
50,000 years ago and now found in 50% of
people previously we thought the stomach
was sterile on account of it being such
an acidic hostile environment yet h
pylori survives the acidic turmoil of
the stomach with a variety of features
that disrupt mucosal defence in its
favor for example it produces an enzyme
called urease that helps protect it from
the surrounding gastric acid h pylori
can make over 1,500 proteins many of
which are dedicated to maximizing its
virulence we still have unanswered
questions like why specific people
develop ulcers at particular times
however we do know individual genetics
other medical problems use of certain
medications smoking and the genetic
diversity of Helicobacter strains all
play a role in particular certain pain
medications used to reduce inflammation
in joints have been discovered to work
with h pylori to create more severe
stomach ulcers dr. Marshall ended up
being fine after his famous albeit
dangerous experiment he ingested a
course of antibiotics similar to the
ones taken now for ulcers
to be treated by simple antibiotics is a
modern triumph for a disease that
previously needed surgery
Marshalls work also reminded us that
scientific progress is not always smooth
but there's value in trusting your
proverbial and sometimes literal gut did
you enjoy this lesson if so please
consider supporting our nonprofit
mission by visiting patreon.com slash
Ted Edie
[Music]